bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors un an après le
renversement d'ibrahim boubacar keita et
deux coups d'état quelle est la
situation actuellement au mali
bonjour 9,6 pour l'habitation
effectivement nous sommes à un an de la
démission du président ibrahim boubacar
keita et aujourd'hui nous sommes mis
avec un deuxième gouvernement de cette
transition qui est dirigé par le gal
kokalla maïga parce que quand vous
l'avez constaté beaucoup d'observateurs
internationaux avisés ont compris de
même que aujourd'hui la situation
politique en tout cas sous l'ère monte à
one et brandao ne permettait pas de
sortir le pays de l'ornière d'où nous
nos membres de
deux du cnt et
la junte militaire un moment donné il a
fallu prendre ses responsabilités et et
demandé une ratification une
rectification de la trajectoire de la
transition parce qu'on allait tout droit
dans le mur donc aujourd'hui tous les
voyants sont ouverts mais ses cheveux
galles kokalla maïga a présenté un plan
d'action qui se situe sur quatre axes
notamment sécuritaires et un pacte
social pour ton clore le tout quel
avenir peut-on espérer pour le mali
quand et comment la stabilité politique
peut-elle revenir selon vous est ce que
vous croyez que l'ordre constitutionnel
peut vraiment être rétablir pour 2022
oui mais il ya des préalables à cela
comme le premier ministre l'a dit lui
même et beaucoup de jeunes et beaucoup
de moyens lui dise l'élection n'est pas
une fin en soi devons-nous faire une
élection pour avoir un pouvoir
illégitime vu que 70% du territoire est
occupé la diaspora malienne n'est
toujours pas comptabilisé et enrôlé pour
lui permettre d'avoir six représentants
dans le futur parlement les futurs
députés donc allons nous faire comme
souley rebecca faire élire un président
avec 1,8 millions de maliens sont sur 20
millions est ce là une véritable
démocratie sentissi poitiers est-ce que
c'est pas comme ça que marche c'est pas
comme ça que ça marche dans une
démocratie pour élire ses dirigeants ses
représentants passent par la case
élection l'an oui mais il ya des prêts
là bas cela vous savez on a connu comme
un de coups d'état depuis l'indépendance
dont je pense qu'à un moment donné il
faut d'abord doter le pays
d'institutions fortes décision valable
et respecté par la totalité des maliens
vous savez un coup d'état n'est pas
anodin généralement nous dans les pays
occidentaux nous condamnons de facto et
par principe les coups d'état mais
peut-être qu'il faudrait surtout
condamné les causes du coup d'état au
lieu du coup d'état la mauvaise
gouvernance le vol des deniers publics
c'est tout cela qui amène les gars ses
relations de ces peuples d'afrique c'est
des jeunes pays qui aura peine 60 ans
d'existence donc en 60 ans on ne peut
pas avoir une démocratie parfaite comme
celle de la france qui date de 1789 ou 7
des états unis faudrait peut-être qu'on
fasse qu'on nous permette de nous
laisser mener notre barque à notre
manière et pas d'injection étrangères ou
d'immixion vous pensez à qui quand vous
dites qu'on ne veut pas de présence
étrangère
dans sa quille et à la fraude non je dis
pas qu'on ne veut pas de présence
étrangère au contraire la france et est
la bienvenue c'est un pays historique ce
qu'un pays c'est un partenaire
stratégique pour le mali et pour le
sahel donc non je ne suis pas dedans
parmi ceux qui disent d'or la france non
non je dis seulement que un moment donné
il faudrait peut-être laissé cette
peuple
décider de sa destinée et non vous faire
du copier coller de la démocratie à
l'occidentale je n'ai rien contre la
démocratie à l'occidentale mais je pense
que nos pays ont d'abord besoin
d'institutions et je répète et
l'élection n'est pas une fin en soi si
c'est pour faire une élection et qu'on
se retrouve quelques mois après avec un
coup d'état retour à la case départ et
celui qui plonge encore dans un boom
sans précédent alors quel rôle la france
at-elle joué dans la transition du
pouvoir après la transformation des
missions de l'opération barkan puisqu'on
l'a dit un tout à l'heure la france est
bien à retirer
amis sans à l'opération barkan au sahel
comment ça s'est passé du coup
oui le trajet au barca liens et à la
mi-juin le prochain par tél mais apte à
kouba qui continue et la france
continuent toujours notamment dans la
formation de l'élite militaire malienne
à la campagne économiquement le mali à
travers l'union européenne donc c'est ce
que je sais ce que je disais tantôt la
france est un partenaire stratégique
pour le mali et pour le seuil comment
est-ce qu'on peut lutter plus
efficacement contre le terrorisme dans
ce contexte là en tout cas on sait que
rien que la semaine dernière 42
personnes ont péri dans le nord du pays
des centaines de personnes ont quitté
leurs villages comment on fait
alors moi pour à mon sens il faudrait il
puis monte en puissance les forces du g5
du sahel parce que c'est une c'est une
bulle 2 transnationales donc faudrait
que le burkina le mali le niger
l'algérie le sénégal doit tous les pays
de la sous région et les pays voisins du
maghreb c'est dans la main mais mène des
actions concrètes on avait vu le départ
des etats-unis de kaboul et de
l'afghanistan
quelques heures après
nous consentons ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui est ce que nous sommes prêts
à cela donc devons nous continuer à
compter uniquement sur la france où
l'union européenne où les nus et soudain
qu'on s'assure qu'on s'est
responsabilisé compte d'autres nous
armer de moyens conséquents confirme
conforme de militaires avec les
dernières techniques de renseignement
pour qu'ils puissent faire face à
l'ennemi qui est animé comme l'idée
c'est une bulleuse transnationales qui
est sans cesse en mouvement dans un
savez le mali avec le mali c'est deux
fois et demie plus grand que la france
donc voilà pour couvrir ça avec tout ce
que cela comporte c'est ce n'est pas
donné un seul pays bas sont brouillées 6
et merci à d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
parlementaires membres du conseil
national de transition du mali merci
beaucoup